THEY HAVE FILED AN OPPOSITION TO
DISMISS THAT ACCUSATION.
>> Laura: HERE NOW TO BRUCE
FONDA'S HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR
AND OFFER OF THE INTRODUCTION TO
THE UNPUBLISHED MUELLER REPORT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
WHY NOT FIGHT THIS OUT IN COURT
IN AN EFFORT TO CLEAR YOUR NAME?
>> WELL, I AM GOING TO.
I HAVE TO DO TWO THINGS.
I HAVE TO DEFEND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT OF EVERY
AMERICAN TO RESPOND TO FALSE
CHARGES, AND SECOND, IF THE CASE
DOES GO TO COURT, TO SHOW THAT
SHE IS A LIAR.
LET ME REPEAT CATEGORICALLY, SHE
MADE UP THE WHOLE STORY.
I NEVER MET THIS WOMAN, IT WAS
PART OF AN EXTORTION PLOT TO
OBTAIN A BILLION DOLLARS FROM A
BUSINESSMAN, THE MAN WHO OWNS A
VICTORIA'S SECRET.
HER OWN LAWYER ADMITTED TO ME ON
TAPE THAT IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ME TO HAVE BEEN IN THE
VARIOUS LOCATIONS AT THOSE TIMES
AND THAT HIS CLIENT IS "WRONG.
HE SIMPLY WRONG."
I COMMISSIONED AN INVESTIGATION
FROM THE FORMER HEAD OF THE FBI
WHO CONCLUDED THAT SHE WAS
WRONG.
HER OWN LAWYERS WITHDREW THE
CHARGES IT SAYING IT A MISTAKE
TO DO SO.
THIS SAME WOMAN WHO ACCUSED ME
ACCUSED BILL CLINTON AND AL GORE
OF BEING ON JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S
ISLAND, AND THE REPORTS OF THE
SECRET SERVICE --
>> Laura: BILL CLINTON DID GO
TO THE ISLAND.
>> NO, HE WAS NEVER ON THE
ISLAND.
HE WAS NEVER ON THE ISLAND.
HE WAS NEVER THERE.
HE ISSUED A STATEMENT THE OTHER
DAY SAYING HE WAS NEVER ON THE
ISLAND AND SECRET SERVICE
CONFIRMED HE WAS NEVER ON THERE
APPEARED TO BE
WHEN THERE ARE DISCREPANCIES.
THERE WERE DISCREPANCIES ON
OTHER MATTERS WITH BILL CLINTON.
HE SAID HE WAS ONLY ON TWO
FLIGHTS, FOUR, TURNS OUT THERE
WERE SIX.
MAINE, THE SECRET SERVICE WAS
ALWAYS WITH HIM.
IT TURNS OUT THEY WEREN'T ALWAYS
WITH HIM.
I WOULDN'T THROW YOURSELF INTO A
BILL CLINTON ON THIS NECESSARIL
NECESSARILY.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT AL GORE.
SHE CLAIMS THAT AL GORE WERE ON
THE ISLAND.
NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT KNOW
JEFFREY EPSTEIN BUT GUESS WHO
AL GORE'S LAWYER WAS?
DAVID BOYCE, THE SAME LAWYER WHO
CLAIMS THAT THIS WOMAN MADE
THESE IMPROPER ALLEGATIONS.
HE COULD'VE EASILY CALLED HIS
CLIENT, AL GORE, AND SAID, WERE
YOU EVER ON JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S
ISLAND?
AND HE WOULD'VE TOLD HER WHAT HE
TOLD EVERYONE ELSE.
NO.
HE WAS NEVER ON THE ISLAND,
DIDN'T KNOW ANYONE AT ALL.
THE INTERESTING THING IS THAT
EPSTEIN IS BEING PROSECUTED NOW
AND THEY ARE NOT USING THIS
WITNESS.
THE FBI IN THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE ARE NOT USING THIS
WITNESS.
>> Laura: DOES SHE HAVE THE
SAME LAWYER?
DOES SHE HAVE THAT SAME LAWYER
THAT YOU SAID YOU HAVE ON TAPE?
STILL REPRESENTING HER?
>> YES.
DAVID BOYCE, WHO HAS AT HIS LAW
FIRM, ONE OF THE WORST ETHICAL
RECORDS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY HAVE MORE ETHICAL CHARGES
AGAINST THEM THAN ANY OTHER LAW
FIRM.
>> Laura: AT THE BIG LAW FIRM.
>> Sean:
BUT HE IS THE HEAD OF THE LAW
FIRM.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH UNETHICAL
CONDUCT BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
IN THE WEINSTEIN CASE.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH QUESTIONABLE
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           I
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           N
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           T
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           E
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           C
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           S
CONDUCT INDEED SARAH           .
HE HAS ABSOLUTELY NO COURT
ABILITY BUT IN THIS CASE HE
KNOWS THE CLIENT MADE UP THE
WHOLE STORY AND HE TOLD ME THAT.
I HAVE IT ON TAPE BEARD ALL I
DID WAS REPEAT BASICALLY ON TAPE
WHAT HE HAD TOLD ME.
>> Laura: THAT IS DECIMATING
IF YOU HAVE.
>> YES, AND IT WILL BE PLAYED IN
COURT.
>> Laura: IF YOU HAVE THAT ON
TAPE, THAT IS BAD.
JOURNALIST VICKI WARD MADE THIS
COMMENT ABOUT -- TOLD ACOSTA YOU
WOULD MAKE MINCEMEAT OUT OF THE
WOMEN.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THE LIGHT THAT THE
"MIAMI HERALD" SHED ON THE
VICTIMS' STORIES THAT WERE
INCREDIBLY POIGNANT AND
CREDIBLE.
REMEMBER BACK IN 2008,
ALAN DERSHOWITZ CHOSE ALEXANDER
ACOSTA THAT HE WAS GOING TO MAKE
MINCEMEAT OF THESE WOMEN.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> THERE IS NO TRUTH TO THAT AT
ALL.
I MET WITH ACOSTA ONLY WANTS THE
GROUP OF LAWYERS.
PROBABLY 50 LAWYERS AND FBI
AGENTS, I'M SURE NOTES WOULD
COME FROM.
I NEVER SAID ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WHAT I DID SAY WAS THERE IS NO
CREDIBLE EVIDENCE THAT EPSTEIN
AT THAT TIME HAD TRANSPORTED ANY
UNDERAGE WOMEN IN INTERSTATE
COMMERCE.
AND THAT WAS REQUIRED.
BY THE WAY, VIRGINIA ROBERTS WAS
NOT UNDER AGE.
THEY HAVE ALL ADMITTED NOW THAT
SHE DIDN'T START WORKING FOR
EPSTEIN UNTIL SHE WAS 17 YEARS
OLD.
AND THAT SHE DOESN'T EVEN CLAIM
THAT SHE HAD SEX WITH HIM.
NUMEROUS PEOPLE SHE HAS ADMITTED
TO HAVING SEX WITH UNTIL SHE WAS
OVER AGE, SO SHE HAS LIED ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
IT'S YOUR JOB AS A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY TO MAKE SURE THE
EVIDENCE IS CREDIBLE EVIDENCE.
>> Laura: I CAN'T BELIEVE I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS
QUESTION, DO YOU STILL REPRESENT
HIM AND WHEN DID YOU STOP
REPRESENTING HIM?
EPSTEIN?
>> I STOPPED REPRESENTING HIM
WHEN THE DEAL WAS MADE AND I
HAVEN'T SEEN HIM IN YEARS.
HIS LAWYERS CALL ME AND ASKED ME
A QUESTION ABOUT THE DEAL, OF
COURSE, AS A LAWYER I HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
LOOK, I WAS INTRODUCED TO HIM BY
THE LADY ROTHSCHILD.
THE PEOPLE HE HUNG OUT WITH AT
THE TIME WERE THE PRESIDENT OF
HARVARD, I RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM
WAS ACADEMIC.
WE WENT TO CONFERENCES, WE HAD
SEMINARS IN HIS OFFICE.
NONE OF US HAD ANY INKLING THAT
HE HAD THIS OTHER LIFE.
AS SOON AS WE LEARNED ABOUT IT,
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF US ENDED ANY
KIND OF A SOCIAL RELATIONSHIP.
I THEN BECAME HIS LAWYER, I AM
PROUD OF THE FACT I REPRESENTED
HIM.
I REPRESENTED A LOT OF
CONTROVERSIAL PEOPLE, AND WE GOT
A DEAL.
SOME PEOPLE CRITICIZE THE DEAL
BUT YOU CAN'T CRITICIZE HIS
DEFENSE ATTORNEY FOR TRYING TO
GET THE BEST DEAL POSSIBLE.
BUT I WANT TO CATEGORICALLY
STATE, I NEVER MET THIS WOMAN.
SHE MADE IT UP COMPLETELY.
I WILL CONTINUE TO SAY THAT
UNTIL THE DAY I DIE AND WHEN I
DIE, MY CHILDREN WILL CONTINUE
TO SAY IT.
IT IS A TOTAL, CATEGORICAL LIVE.
>> Laura: WE APPRECIATE YOU